The jogan Experience everybody [__]
their pants and everybody's falling
exactly yeah I [__] my pants just last
week thought I was going to fart in my
house I felt it come out wet I was like
you son of a you know sometimes that's
kind of nice though you get a midday
shower I was on my way out the door oh
that's was on my way to do a podcast oh
[__] my pants your pants damn
it rinse them off in the sink yeah I'm
usually good about shs I guess you have
to yeah yeah true I usually can like
sometimes I surprise myself I'm like I
definitely [__] myself and I'm like no I
didn't one time I was coming home from
ass and I farted one time I was coming
home from Fear Factor and I just I was
fighting it I was fighting it was a
battle was a battle it was like oh God
it was cramp and I filled my pants I
mean filled I mean filled like where I
immediately felt it in my socks like
right away I was like oh good lord I
mean it it rocketed out of my [__]
the the underwear was about as effective
as our border wall it went down my legs
I felt it in the back of my legs
instantly I was like oh Christ it was an
explosion I was holding I was holding
back as long as I could you released it
was like hanging off of a bridge on a
and you realize you can't pull yourself
up Let Go that's it where were you how
far from car I do not remember I
remember being in my car and just
unloading on my SUV
seats Alexis Alexis SUV I just filled
that front seat up [__] how you clean
that out what was the process I took it
to the car wash bro oh my I cleaned it
out myself and then I brought it to the
car wash to get it detailed I didn't
tell them I [__] myself they they got in
the car like holy what the [__] dude
what the
[__] the feir factor guy just gave us a
shitty truck hopefully had leather seats
man leather seats oh yeah they were
leather good that's good for dumps cloth
lot better than cloth bro it gets in
that foam that's I'm saying it never
comes out do in your foam you got to cut
that foam out dude if someone throws up
in your car it smells forever you got to
burn it and say uh caught on fire and
bring it to the dealership I did not
[__] myself definitely didn't [__]
myself but I caught my front seat on
fire [__] my my friend [__] himself at
work when we worked together and he
drove home like sneakily to like change
his pants we were like younger too we're
in high school and his mom was outside
and she was like what are you doing he's
like I [__] my pants and she made them
get undressed and host them off
outside oh my God he a [__]
embarrassing oh God yeah it's just
embarrassing as a guest dude getting
hosed by your mom CU you [__] your pants
your mom's clean up your [__] he said
garden hose he was pulling into the
driveway some on it to make a
blast
[Laughter]
just really focusing cleaning on you got
to
just stand there I know Mom hose water's
[__]
freezing it's cold he said he was in his
driveway saw his house and it just lost
he's like I lost it dude the at the goal
line just the goal line breaks his leg
like a Clyde's
deal at the Go I mean that is where it
gets you the second you I wasn't even I
wasn't even close to my house I drove I
drove with the windows down smelling my
own [__] for a solid 25 minutes god
dude like what was going through your
head though like did you accept it were
you like this is unacceptable I [__]
myself I'm like what are you going to do
dude I I had ruthless diarrhea whatever
the hell was going on yeah you sick yeah
it must have been I don't remember I
just I all I remember is that feeling
the feel feeling of like knowing you're
going to
lose I have I don't want black and I
feel
it it feels so good though dude to just
be like was horrible just give in be
like [__] if I had made it to the toilet
it would have been amazing dude it would
have been one of the greatest victories
in my career I Matt gave me uh a bunch
of like micro do mushrooms oh yeah took
more than I should and I was just on a
walk I was like I'll just have a nice
walk around New York dude I got like two
blocks away and I was like my stomach
just went
and I was like oh no dude I sprinted
home I sprinted up Tommy was downstairs
and heard me run up the steps and he was
like what the [__] was that I've got
some great victories in my [__]
career too that was one of the big
victories you get to the ball like a the
keyworks at the front door you're like
yes yes you you keep those muscles tight
till you get to the bowl and you're
wonder you're quivering when you're
pulling your pants down you know like I
don't know if I'm going to make it dude
your teeth get all weird at the
buzzer the three-pointers in the air
game time dude I got I got jammed in an
Uber on the way to the airport it was
like 6:00 in the morning and it just all
of a sudden on the way I was like oh
[__] and I had like 20 minutes and I was
in the lady's car like sitting on one
ass cheek it was so bad I had like my
ass up and I was just letting out these
like any fart could have and I was like
I wanted to tell like I'm sorry I was
[__] I was farting in the back of
her car I could not do it I had a
release and you're sitting sideways she
looks back did you say sorry no she
looks back at you're
launching I was at Terminal sideways
launch position I was at Terminal C and
I'm like Terminal A is fine cuz I like
where you going to I was like Terminal C
and I got there I'm like Terminal A is
fine Dam you jump at the airport at the
at the entrance where all the homeless
people go in cuz anyone can get in I
made it and I sat down I saw there was
no toilet paper and I went [__] it and I
had to just let it out and luckily dude
I went in my school bag and my wife gave
me packet of Kleenex I saw them put it
in my bag like weeks ago I'm like I
don't need that [__] [__] in my bag
she threw it in my bag and I went what
an angel pull the kleenex out wipe my
ass inition [__] woman's touch after
using these robot toilets to clean your
butt bro I get sad when I have to just
wipe it cuz I know it's gross it sucks
dude wiping your ass it's gross you're
just smearing [__] all over yourself all
the way you're like rubbing it to the
point where you look at the tissue and
it's reasonable
yeah oh [__] my ass itches like the are
so nice I got to put one on so nice
bought one from my old house and I try
to connect it and the [__] water
sprayed everywhere so I got to hire a
professional yeah hire somebody yeah I
got to get a bed it's so nice dude in
the [__] bathroom in the comedy club
oh yeah it's nice we didn't have one for
sh in there dude you [__] in the one
bathroom I [__] every time I do stand I
have I can't help there's a button that
says defecate you ever hit that button
yes brother I hit all the buttons really
that's a pipe cleaner I haven't dumped
there I don't think bro dude um what
does it say North America through the
1700s people were still wiping whatever
they had on hand oh yeah most common
things were corn cobs and seash shells
paus on the corn cob seashells they
scraped their [__] with seashells but
by the 1800s paper was becoming more
widely available finally in 1857 a New
Yorker named Joseph Gay introduced the
first patented toilet paper boss wow
hero 187
1857 so until 1857 everyone was just the
Romans clean their behind seong that
seems like a good beats the [__] out of
stick yeah yeah a lot of places in the
world keep like a dish of water in the
Middle East you keep a dish of water
above your toilet and use one hand to
like splash water on your ass
huh a wiping T interesting I think
that's the move the move is the sponge
cuz if you use the sponge then you can
clean the sponge off yeah you can reuse
it it's green oh throw this away Jamie
yeah just a pile of sponges in the toil
you clean your sponge piece of [__] your
sponge with everybody gets one sponge it
goes with your voter ID on the end of a
spear SE sponge go get another one you
can go you don't have to put it on the
end of a spear you hold it in your hand
like a gentleman they would get old
though a stick it's like you're buffing
like when you're buffing your hood just
buff your [__] with a SE a sponge
actually that is nice that seems like a
good I thing that for a car would feel
great on your I
might test a sponge might break out
toilet and right next to the toilet you
got like a basin the water's flowing you
dunk your sponge in there clean it out
sound water dripping in unless unless
you just got a mess chunky thick the
shower frozen yogurt you're never
getting it out of the sponge it's deep
it's all over your ass cheeks you're
wiping your legs it's all the way up
your back it's dripping down your legs
now the [__] did I do Shar by fellow
butt wipers oh they were used and shared
you don't have your own of course why
would you have your own Jamie yeah it's
[__] Rome dude visitor okay so if one
of the Fara visitors had intestinal
worms all the others would carry them
home too without any knowledge of how
diseases spread the overall Roman toilet
setup could hardly be called hygienic by
modern standards yeah you know you know
they test they told me to test kids for
worms they said put a piece of Scotch
tape on your kid's butthole while it's
sleeping and the worms come out of the
butthole at night and they'll get stuck
to the Scotch tape what
yeah I a doctor tell my wife this today
don't you have to like shine a light on
your kid's [__] to see the worms
coming out at night they hopefully well
they happen to I heard that story but
they want us to put Scotch tape on the
bee hole Mayo Clinic says to do that too
pressing adhesive side of a piece of
transparent tape to the skin around the
anus of the person you suspect as
pinworms as soon as the person awakens
the eggs stick to the tape when you tape
take the tape to your appointments the
doctor could look at pin worms or eggs
under a microscope interesting is that
[__]
crazy